we're the students United and nothing
can Tamp us we're taking our message to
all parts of Campus the
administrations who we're trying to find
we want to know why our tuition's so
high so we check the yoga studio they're
not there the coffee shop ice cream
machine everywhere the son the climbing
wall pull the high dive we want to know
why our tuition so high with the
students united we won't be divided
we'll get what we want oh and don't try
to fight it our SAT ACT scores are
Sublime but there still awesome answers
we struggle to
find we're protesting privilege we're
marching the streets with the golf and
the Dan and equestrian teams we need a
safe space from the intolerant can't you
see your words hurt me you dumb piece of
we're the students united we won't
be divided we'll get what we want and
don't try to fight it r a t a scores are
Sublime but there still awesome answers
we struggle to
find we're chanting with with Vigor
we're chanting with rage we won't accept
less than a good living wage at a job
interview we told them how we felt but
the last thing we heard they went with
someone else with the students united we
won't be divided we'll get what we want
and don't try to fight it our SAT ACT
scores are Sublime but there's still
awesome answers we struggle to find yes
there's still a some answers we struggle
to
[Music]
find